UP THE PLAY WILL HELP WITH THAT
AND WHEN WINGER SUPPORT ON
FACETHE BLUE JACKETS GET OVER T
BLUE LINE AND INTO THE OFFENSIV.
I DON'T THINK HE WAS IN  OFF
THE CROSSBAR.
SHOT WIDE.
KLINGENBERG WITH THE LONGSHOTS,
FOR HEISKANEN.WER PLAY.
IN ANYTHING, SPORTS OR LIFE.
THEY ARE GOING TO T
BACK TO THE MIDDLE.AUTHENTIC.
IN FRONT THERE.
HE CAN'T GET A STICK ON IT GRID.
>> THEY GOT PULLED INTO THIS JE
ACROSS ICE, AND  BLOCK THAT
REGENERATE THE REST OF THE WAY.
>> JAKE BEAN FLOATS ONE IN OFF
THAT
TO PLAY IT.
BACK I
IT WENT TO REVIEW AND OVERTURN
CONVERSATION SO THAT IS A GOOD .
ALL FOUR DALLAS FORWARDS
CONGREGATE ON THE WALL.
THE PUCK  IN
MORE PURSUIT OF
THE SHOP BY BJORKSTRAND.
LAINE.S THAT SHOT.
HOLDS ON.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THE DALLAS
STARS ARE JUST GUESSING HERE TH.
PLAY..
THE BLUE JACKETS ARE DOING THAT
EXACT THING TONIGHT T LIKE A TE
SHOTS AS THE P
HOLTBY.
SEGUIN.
AROUND FOUR